we will begin with this a Border
Patrol's largest migrant processing
center is closed for now over fears of a
potentially deadly flu outbreak a 16
year old from Guatemala
Carlos Gregorio Hernandez Vasquez died
on Monday after coming down with the flu
he had recently been processed at that
facility in McAllen Texas he is the
fifth underage migrant taken into
custody to die since December some
members of Congress want answers about
the growing number of deaths among the
16 thousand people in border patrol
custody
Omar Villafranca is in Dallas Omar good
morning good morning Hernandez was in
Border Patrol custody for seven days
during that time he was actually
diagnosed with the flu and moved to a
different facility but by law he should
have been moved out of Border Patrol
control in three days and should have
never died in their custody this is
outrageous and it's unacceptable Joaquin
Castro is the chairman of the
Congressional Hispanic Caucus on Tuesday
he said the death of carlos hernandez
and other migrant minors should set off
alarms prior to the trump administration
CBP had not had a child die on their
watch for over a decade border patrol is
facing an unprecedented situation
last month it apprehended nearly ninety
nine thousand people that's more than
double the amount of apprehensions in
april last year last June Gayle King
visited the same facility where Carlos
was processed and spoke to migrants at a
nearby refugee center board er Patrol
says Hernandez was apprehended last week
after illegally crossing the border in
South Texas the 16 year old was brought
to Border Patrol's central processing
center in McAllen on May 13th
this past Sunday he was diagnosed with
the flu and transferred to a different
Border Patrol station to prevent it from
spreading to others the next day he was
found dead but should all be outraged
ephra no livadas is an attorney with the
Texas Civil Rights Project according to
federal law unaccompanied minors must be
transferred within 72 hours to the
Office of refugee resettlement a special
division that
deals with children that never happened
Carla was there for almost a full week
that's entirely unacceptable
Hernandez's family back in Guatemala is
devastated okay let's go so Tracy I want
to know why he died his sister said he
was already in the hands of immigration
we spoke to Hernandez's brother who
lives in New Jersey his face is blurred
to protect his identity so he told us he
never thought something like this would
happen to his brother in what was
supposed to be a better place I'm
convinced that if these were white
children who were dying people would be
up in arms the life of brown
spanish-speaking children was valued the
same as every other life this wouldn't
be happening
Border Patrol says it did a welfare
check on Hernandez an hour before he was
found dead now keep in mind this was not
in a hospital DHS's Office of Inspector
General will be leading this
investigation Gayle Omar this is a
heartbreaking and really upsetting to me
because you certainly feel for the
family and I'm curious about why the
kids aren't taken to the hospital number
one so what's the procedure if there is
a sick child in custody and most
importantly what are they doing to make
sure this does not happen again well
Gail when they're processed in of course
they're kind of diagnosed to see if they
have any sickness but with that many
people that are coming in at the border
obviously things can fall through the
cracks one of the big things that people
are asking is why was this kid still in
Border Patrol custody and not with Orr
which is designed to help really focus
on children and their health now as far
as what's being done in the future
we have no idea Gail five kids have died
since December we're waiting for answers
from the government
Omar thank you very much in addition to
those five kids 282 fatalities along the
border people trying to avoid those
facilities and avoid border patrol
altogether it's definitely a
humanitarian crisis that is exactly
these families don't speak English don't
know the language they think their kids
are coming to a better place it's very
upsetting yeah it is for children